La postérité ne sait pas du tout que ça n'a pas été enregistré.
Est-ce que la méditation méta a un effet sur le corps ?
Est-ce que vous avez vu un film qui s'appelle...
Qu'est-ce que vous savez ?
C'est un film sur la science, sur la compréhension
disons, du corps humain et de l'univers.
Tout ce que j'ai appris, disons, c'est sur les cellules de notre corps.
Disons, nos cellules ont différents
le senseur qui réagit disons selon les hormones qui arrivent quand disons quelqu'un est toujours déprimé disons
La membrane extérieure de la cellule développe de plus en plus de senseurs qui vont recevoir les hormones produites par l'état de pression.
Oui, ça...
Plus il y a de senseurs, disons, pour recevoir les hormones de la dépression, moins il y a de senseurs pour recevoir les hormones de la joie.
Alors, ça signifie que pour quelqu'un qui est toujours, disons, déprimé, quand arrive quelque chose de joyeux, elle ne sent pas du tout la joie, mais toujours la dépression.
Alors, ça arrivera un temps où la personne ne peut plus, disons, se sentir heureuse ou bien aura des difficultés de se sentir heureuse.
Il y a, disons, un feedback, c'est-à-dire un échange
L'esprit et le corps.
Quand l'esprit ne se sent pas heureux, il va produire une sensation
disons, pour que le corps, disons, à son tour ne se sent pas heureux non plus.
Quand l'esprit n'est pas heureux, le corps n'est pas heureux, il se sent lourd et il se sent déprimé.
Alors, ça veut dire que quand l'esprit
sentent que le corps est lourd et déprimé, l'esprit, à son tour, se sent beaucoup plus déprimé.
Alors, ça veut dire que l'esprit et le corps se renforcent de plus en plus dans leur dépression mutuelle.
Et quand vous observez la réciprocation, c'est la même chose.
Quand vous mettez votre attention sur la respiration, la respiration va se calmer et entraînera aussi, disons, l'esprit qui va se calmer à son tour.
À mesure que l'esprit, disons, se calme, le corps, disons, se calme à son tour.
À mesure que le corps se calme,
le corps a besoin de moins d'oxygène, ça veut dire qu'à ce moment-là la respiration devient de plus en plus fine.
À ce moment-là, disons à son tour, quand la respiration devient de plus en plus fine, la tension s'aiguise pour essayer d'attraper la respiration qui, elle, est devenue fine.
Alors ça veut dire que l'esprit et le corps
s'entraînent mutuellement, disons, dans ce calme de plus en plus profond.
Quand nous pratiquons la méditation de l'amour universelle,
nous produisons des hormones, des beaux hormones qui vont produire, disons, de belles sensations.
Alors, nos cellules vont produire de plus en plus de sensors
qui vont produire, disons, de plus en plus de sensations, de belles sensations.
Alors, disons, à mesure que nous offrons du Metta, disons, n'importe où où nous nous trouvons, disons, durant la journée,
nous allons constater que notre corps va, disons, devenir de plus en plus beau, avoir des belles sensations.
Et ça va produire, disons, des sensations, comment ça s'appelle, saines.
Les belles pensées, les beaux sentiments, ils ont une belle influence sur le corps.
Oui.
Pourquoi ma histoire m'occupe-t-elle si la joie est là ?
Pourquoi, disons, je suis rattrapé par mon passé quand je ressens le bonheur ?
Disons, si le bonheur est là, pourquoi mon passé revient si le bonheur n'est pas là ?
L'histoire ici, c'est notre conditionnement.
Parce que ce conditionnement est très fort, très puissant.
Quand notre conditionnement, disons, surgit et nous pousse à agir de manière inefficace ou bien de manière impure, nous devrons
disons, être humble devant ce fait-là.
Oui, tu ressens l'humilité.
Oui, oui.
Nous ne pouvons pas, disons, nous battre contre notre conditionnement, disons, le détruire.
Tout ce que nous pouvons faire, c'est, disons, d'être conscients de son conditionnement et de le laisser s'en aller.
À cause de notre faiblesse, de notre manque de volonté, nous, la plupart du temps, nous abandonnons.
Prenons par exemple quelqu'un qui fume.
La personne sait très bien que la fumée, lui, peut le tuer.
Parce que ce n'est pas tellement évident, mais à cause, disons, de la faiblesse et le manque de discipline, disons, la personne continue à fumer parce que, disons, ça lui rend plaisir.
Ça lui donne du plaisir.
Le problème avec l'addiction, c'est que l'addict se sent seulement naturel ou normal quand il est addict.
Disons, le problème des, qu'on s'appelle, des addictions, on dit là... Des dépendances.
Des dépendances, c'est que la personne ne se sent seulement normale quand elle est dans des états de dépendance.
Quand elles arrêtent leur dépendance, elles se sentent anormales.
Donc, se battre contre ça est très difficile.
Disons, se battre contre sa dépendance est très difficile.
Disons, aller à l'encontre de la dépendance est très difficile.
Après le chèque arrêté, la personne va être dans une période de sevrage.
Après, la personne se sent en confiance de ne pas fumer encore.
Et puis, à une fête, quelqu'un leur offre une cigarette.
Et ils disent, « Oh, bien, j'en ai juste une.
» Mais ensuite, le tout habit est le kick-start.
Alors, les mauvaises habitudes reviennent.
C'est comme si vous démarrez une motocyclette.
Alors, la personne filme de nouveau.
Disons, pour nous battre contre notre conditionnement, il faut laisser notre désir se dissoudre.
parce que c'est là comme un petit animal juste en attendant le biscuit oui
Est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer, disons, la différence entre le mental, l'esprit, et l'intellect ?
Il y a tout le processus de la perception.
Alors, il y a aussi le processus de connaissance.
Disons, d'appréhender la perception, de connaître la perception.
Dans ce processus, il y a le processus de la...
de la sensation, qui est, disons, des couleurs, des sons qu'on perçoit.
Après, il y a, disons, le processus d'étiqueter
de mettre un nom, un mot.
C'est ce processus de détectage qui devient, disons, l'intellect.
Alors, le processus de...
des perceptions combinées avec l'intellect qui produit, disons, la fabrication des images.
Quand ce phénomène est très développé,
cela produit l'État, disons, l'aide de théâtre.
Nous pouvons en abuser, disons, pour produire de la pornographie.
Tout ça est compris dans le terme bouddhiste
de, disons, de l'esprit, un mana ?
– Nama.
– N
C'est ce processus que vous devez purifier avec votre pratique de vipassana.
Ce que vous devrez faire, c'est que vous devrez dissocier ce processus qui s'appelle le processus de conscience, non, désolé, d'attention, sati, d'attention et de sagesse.
Oui ?
c'est-à-dire que vous essayez de dissocier ça c'est-à-dire to take out the quality of satipanya disons la qualité disons qui constitue l'attention et la chagresse satipanya attention et chagresse chagresse more intuitive intelligence intelligence intuitive intelligence intuitive
Tout ce que nous devons faire, c'est que nous devons, disons, prendre tous ces phénomènes comme objets
Les sensations, les sentiments, les émotions, les images.
C'est la découverte de ce qu'est Satipaññā, qui est l'éveil.
C'est la découverte de ce que signifie l'attention et la sagesse intuitive qui constituent le but.
Oui, le but.
Désolé Venerable, j'ai une question.
Vous avez une question, vous êtes le traducteur.
Non, non, non.
J'aimerais améliorer mon compréhension.
C'est-à-dire que dans cette magma, nous devons prendre tous les éléments et les prendre comme objectifs de notre analyse.
Alors, disons, dans ce processus de désassembler tous ces éléments, disons, en tant qu'objet, nous allons devenir un observateur.
Alors, disons, ce sentiment d'observateur qui est un sentiment de soi doit être aussi un objet d'observation.
C'est vrai ?
C'est correct ?
Oui, oui.
Alors, disons, cet observateur ne peut pas être nous.
Alors, cette sensation subtile, disons, d'avoir un soi ne peut pas être réelle.
Ça ne peut pas être toi.
C'est un objet.
Parce que c'est un objet.
Si c'est un objet, ça ne peut pas être le sujet.
C'est très simple.
Si c'est un objet, ça ne peut pas être soi.
Tu vois?
Oui ?
Est-ce que j'ai une autre question ?
Oui, une autre !
Donc, à la fin du jour, qui observe ?
C'est-à-dire le savoir ?
Le...
Alors, c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on doit atteindre, c'est de se poser la question, est-ce que tout ce qu'on a observé, est-ce que c'est en isolation, c'est-à-dire de manière séparée, isolée ?
Ou bien qu'il y a d'autres choses en plus ?
Disons, l'explication du Buddha est arrivée à un point où on ne peut plus expliquer avec les termes, disons, normaux.
Désolé ?
« Such is the delusion of the mind that if it can put a label on it, it thinks it knows it.
» Alors, disons, tant que l'esprit, disons, peut mettre un étiquetage sur un objet, l'esprit pense que, disons, qu'il, comment ça s'appelle ?
Qu'il le connaisse.
Qu'il connaisse.
Qu'il le sait.
Oui.
C'est comme ça que le Vénérable dit que l'esprit est un menteur.
Ce n'est pas tout le temps.
On a dit que nos sensations, nos sentiments, nos pensées ne sont pas nous, ne nous appartiennent pas, alors comment peut-on défaire ?
Comment peut-on les arrêter ?
Il ne faut pas les arrêter.
Alors si vous arrêtez, vous devenez un bloc.
Il faut très juste seulement les purifier.
Alors, la première pensée que le Bouddha a à son évêque, il dit, qui je peux aider, à qui je peux enseigner ?
Alors, disons, la sagesse qu'on a, naturellement, elle veut s'exprimer d'elle-même.
Sinon, ce ne sera pas la sagesse.
On ne peut pas séparer la sagesse du comportement éthique, moral.
Oui.
Ça c'est, disons, l'octuple sentier du Bouddha.
La compréhension juste, la...
L'attitude correcte.
Alors si l'attitude est correcte, à ce moment-là, il y aura, disons, les paroles justes, les moyens d'existence justes.
Oui.
Nous ne voulons pas arrêter rien, nous voulons seulement le purifier.
Mon esprit occidental, disons, lutte avec le concept de non-soi.
Si les pensées, les sentiments ne sont pas moi, alors à qui ils appartiennent ?
Alors qui aime, qui donne naissance et qui un jour meurt ?
Le Bouddha n'a pas dit qu'il n'y a pas un soi C'est une technique
C'est une technique pour réaliser les notions « ce n'est pas moi, ça ne m'appartient pas ».
Quand je m'assieds en méditation et que j'ai une douleur, la sensation est observée, disons, de l'extérieur, ce n'est pas moi, ni ça ne m'appartient pas.
Tout ce que je peux ressentir, ce que je peux expérimenter, je peux voir que ce n'est pas moi, ni ne m'appartient pas.
Quand nous étions petits bébés jusqu'à l'âge de 4 mois, il n'y avait pas de monde objectif.
Un bébé de jusqu'à quatre mois, pour lui, il n'y a pas, disons, de monde extérieur subjectif.
Pour lui, tout est à lui, tout est lui.
Il n'y a pas de dualité entre lui et le monde extérieur.
Il n'y a rien, il n'y a pas de langage.
Alors, après quatre mois, il y a quelque chose qui ressort et qui fait la différence entre, disons, l'enfant et le monde extérieur.
Et d'abord la maman.
À l'âge de trois ans, disons, il est très conscient de son corps.
Ok.
Il faudrait prendre le processus de sortir tout ce qui est en nous et de l'extériorer, de l'extérioriser comme la salle qui est à l'extérieur de nous-mêmes.
Le monde qu'on connaît est le monde que l'esprit a fabriqué.
Personne ne peut nier que quand nous quittons cette salle, cette salle continue à exister.
Mais votre expérience de la salle, ce que vous connaissez de la salle, la salle que vous connaissez est votre salle, ce n'est pas ma salle.
Oui.
Donc nous vivons tous dans des univers parallèles.
Nous vivons finalement dans des univers parallèles.
Je me pose la question, comment on a pu se communiquer ?
Pour nous, il n'y a pas de monde à l'extérieur, il y a seulement dans notre esprit.
C'est affreux, effrayant.
Alors, ça veut dire que je me pose la question, est-ce que je vois le monde, disons, de manière réelle ?
C'est pour cela que j'achète un peu auprès de moi, disons, tous les gens qui ont la même opinion que moi pour me rassurer.
C'est ce que les religions font.
Il y a un Dieu.
Certaines religions disent qu'il y a un Dieu.
Pour prouver ça, ils ont dit que comme il y a des millions qui croient en Dieu, ça veut dire que Dieu existe.
Après, il y a une religion très étrange qui dit qu'il n'y a pas de Dieu.
Alors, après, le bouddhisme rassemble tous les gens qui disent, qui croient qu'il n'y a pas un Dieu.
Qui sait ?
Qui est-ce, alors, qui meurt, qui donne naissance et qui meurt un jour ?
En un seul sens, personne.
Parce que ce corps, par exemple,
Ce corps est un assemblage de cellules qui vivent leur propre vie.
Alors, est-ce que vous savez qu'est-ce qui se passe dans votre moelle épinière ?
Vous savez que...
Les cellules, disons, les globules rouges et blanches.
Est-ce que vous avez rencontré, disons, l'hémoglobine de blanche, rouge ?
Nous savons seulement comment, disons, le goût du sang.
Mais on ne sait pas du tout ce que c'est le sang.
Hein ?
C'est que c'est le sang.
Alors, si vous êtes le sang, si vous dansez au sang et que vous coupez votre main et que le sang s'écoule, c'est-à-dire que, à ce moment-là, vous perdez votre soi, votre vous, oui.
Quand le corps...
disparaît disons le corps disparaît ce n'est pas vous si c'est vous vous pouvez dire voilà ne mourrez pas maintenant si vous vous investiguez disons de manière plus approfondie
disons ces choses-là, vous allez voir que, disons, ça va saboter votre minet, votre idée de soi.
Et c'est effrayant.
Mais c'est très intéressant.
Mais c'est quand même très intéressant.
Si vous n'avez vraiment pas...
Comment vous pouvez expliquer, disons, si vous n'avez quelqu'un, s'il n'y a personne, voilà, comment vous expliquez cet état ?
Ce que nous sommes, ce sont des métaphores.
C'est des métaphores pour la chagresse.
Ou bien un manque de chagresse.
C'est-à-dire que c'est la faculté de savoir, disons la nature du Bouddha.
Quand nous aimons quelqu'un, nous aimons la nature du Bouddha qui est dans la personne.
Nous sommes en train de nourrir la nature du Bouddha qui est en la personne, à travers la personnalité de la personne.
Alors, qui aime ?
L'amour est une attitude qui provient de la chagresse.
Si il n'y a pas d'I, où est la source de l'amour ?
La question est
La question doit être, quel est le but de mon existence ?
Le but de l'existence est d'atteindre ce bonheur et la libération.
Et c'est une qualité de ce processus que plus j'en ai, plus je veux le partager.
C'est la qualité de cette quête, plus j'ai cet amour, plus je voulais le partager avec d'autres personnes.
Est-ce que cela vous aide?
quand le Bouddha est atteint l'éveil il n'est pas devenu un schizophrène
Tout ce trait de caractère et, disons, trait de personnalité
devienne le véhicule, c'est-à-dire toutes ses actions et toutes ses paroles, c'est-à-dire que son savoir peut, à travers ce véhicule, s'exprimer, disons, cette connaissance.
Cette sagesse n'est pas attachée aux métaphores.
La métaphore signifie, disons, le corps.
la parole et les actions.
C'est comme une peinture, le peintre va dire que ce n'est pas, disons, mes émotions,
Mais c'est un moyen pour moi d'exprimer ces émotions, c'est un média.
Pour quelqu'un qui est éveillé, disons, son corps, ses paroles et ses actions, c'est comme un chef-d'œuvre.
L'attitude de l'amour, la compassion et tous ceux-là avec Nibbana.
Quand Sariputta est demandé « Comment pouvez-vous parler de la joie de Nibbana quand il n'y a pas d'émotions là-bas ?
» Quelqu'un avait demandé à Sariputta
Comment on peut atteindre l'état de Nibbana quand il n'y a pas de pensée ni d'émotion ?
Il dit que c'est l'absence totale des émotions qui est la bénédiction ultime de Nibbana.
Maintenant, quand vous méditez et un beau sentiment apparaît,
Alors, disons, quand vous avez une sensation acrabelle qui surgit et que vous l'observez, vous allez vous demander, disons, est-ce que cette...
Quelle est la sensation, l'émotion dans votre acte d'observer, de voir ?
L'amour, la compassion qui sont exprimées, ce sont des expressions de la nature du Bouddha qui sont en nous.
Qu'est-ce?
Il ne faut pas comprendre l'artiste et l'œuvre adulte.
Donc l'artiste peut être ce qu'on appelle Dieu dans d'autres religions.
Ah non, quand tu parles de Dieu, c'est quelque chose d'autre, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est-à-dire, bon, la question c'est est-ce que l'artiste peut être considéré comme Dieu, disons, des autres religions ?
C'est une autre question, c'est une autre... Ça apporte beaucoup, ça apporte beaucoup de choses sur la création et des choses, tu sais.
Ça va nous amener à des débats sur la création.
Si vous voulez quitter, disons, allez-y.
Vous pouvez aller manger un peu plus, il n'y a pas des heures.
Est-ce que vous pourriez faire la distinction dans le bouddhisme entre l'amour et la compassion ?
L'amour est décrit comme l'amitié.
Le désir d'être un ami de quelqu'un.
Donc, tout ce que vous voudriez d'un bon ami, c'est Metta.
Tout ce que vous voudriez d'un bon ami, c'est Metta.
Vous pensez qu'ils sont laissés en colère ?
La compassion vient du désir d'éliminer la souffrance de quelqu'un.
La compassion c'est le désir de diminuer la souffrance d'autrui.
C'est différent.
L'opposé de l'amour c'est la haine.
L'opposé de la compassion c'est la cruauté.
C'est-à-dire que vous...
Est-ce que vous pouvez...
Est-ce que vous pouvez illustrer, disons, un exemple, la relation entre une émotion forte et les sensations dans le corps ?
Et comment nous pouvons utiliser cette relation pour développer notre pleine conscience ?
L'une des premières, comment ça s'appelle, intuitions, c'est le vipassanā, le niveau.
Il y a seize niveaux d'intuition dans le vipassanā.
dont le dernier, disons, conduit à l'état nirvana.
Quelqu'un qui va dans ce chemin est appelé Sotapanna, celui qui est entré dans le chemin.
Disons
Ceux qui ont atteint les quatre premiers niveaux, disons, vont être, disons, beaucoup plus éveillés.
Quelqu'un qui va revenir une seule fois, quelqu'un qui ne revient plus, et Arahant.
La première intuition du Vipassana c'est de séparer le corps de l'esprit.
Ça c'est le premier niveau de diminuer la notion de soi.
Parce que le soi doit être fait d'un seul bloc, il ne peut pas être fait en pièces.
disons, fait de différents éléments, de différentes parties.
Voir que le corps ou bien que les sensations sont deux énergies différentes, c'est le commencement, disons, des soutres, la notion du moi.
Donc c'est comme ça que votre connaissance, ici la personne dit connaissance de la conscience, mais le développement de notre connaissance commence dans le processus de Vipassana en séparant le corps de la tête.
Disons, la chagresse va commencer à se développer à partir de la séparation entre le corps et l'esprit.
Alors, il y a la sensation, disons, d'élévation et d'abaissement.
Après, il y a la conscience, disons, de cet élèvement et de l'abaissement qui sont deux processus différents.
Dans l'histoire...
Disons d'un jeune garçon, je crois qu'il est sauvé par le prière du Bouddha de ses disciples.
D'une mort certaine.
Il y a la question du karma individuel et l'influence des prières.
Comment ça peut être réconcilié avec l'idée que le Bouddha n'est pas
un intercesseur entre nous et un être suprême qui n'existe pas dans le bouddhisme et la responsabilité individuelle.
Quand nous parlons de karma cela a à voir avec le processus de libération Nous ne parlons seulement de ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes ce qui vient de l'extérieur
Ce n'est pas nécessaire que ce soit créé par notre propre karma.
Dans le bouddhisme, comme dans les sciences naturelles, il y a la loi de la nature.
Si vous êtes, disons, tué par le tsunami, ça ne veut pas dire que dans votre vie passée vous avez noyé des milliers de rats.
Disons, dans votre...
histoire génétique, disons, si vous attrapez une maladie génétique.
Ça ne veut pas dire que vous méritez, disons, cette maladie parce que dans votre vie passée, vous avez tué quelqu'un.
Si vous êtes né dans une famille qui vous est bénéfique ou bien qui vous est défavorable, ça ne veut pas dire que vous le méritez.
Ce que vous méritez, c'est l'état mental que vous avez dans ces situations précises.
Il y a des personnes qui meurent avec un état mental calme.
Et d'autres meurent effrayés, disons, durant les tsunamis.
Ça, c'est leur karma.
Il y a des personnes qui ont des maladies graves et qui sont contents, et d'autres qui sont aigris, effrayés.
Ça, c'est leur karma personnel.
Ceux qui sont nés dans des familles horribles ou bien des familles unies,
la réaction disons dans ces situations ça c'est leur karma personnel alors disons quand on parle de cette personne qui
qui va vers une mort certaine.
On ne parle pas de son karma personnel, mais on parle de son environnement, de son environnement, d'autres causes.
Quand le Bouddha ou bien ses disciples ont prié et ont envoyé leur bienveillance envers cette personne, ils peuvent très bien avoir changé la circonstance dans laquelle la personne était, qui allait les causer à mourir.
ils peuvent très bien changer les circonstances dans lesquelles la personne, disons, va à une mort certaine.
Ça nous amène à nous poser la question, est-ce que, disons, nos prières ou bien nos...
disons ce que nous on répand comme bienveillance a un effet ça c'est à chacun de juger si par exemple j'envoie la bienveillance pour quelqu'un qui est malade
et que j'espère qu'il va guérir, disons, si guéri, je ne peux pas prouver l'effet de mes actes.
Le fait que l'esprit affecte, disons,
La matérialité, c'est à chacun de juger.
Elle est une guérisseuse.
Elle parle d'un accident
duquel une dame a été tuée, l'accident en voiture.
La, disons,
quand la dame était tuée elle sort disons son esprit sort de son corps et observe la file de voiture disons qui passe tout le monde tout le monde est en train de jurer et était en colère et une seule personne a prié pour elle et elle a vu l'énergie aller en haut et puis revenir en bas sur sa propre tête
et elle a vu que l'énergie, disons, de la personne qui a prié est remontée et redescendre sur la même personne.
Elle est revivifiée et après elle retourne dans son corps.
Et elle se rappelle de la plaque minéralogique de l'autre personne.
Et elle va le rencontrer et lui offrir un cadeau.
Si vous le croyez ou non, c'est à vous de juger.
Quand le Bouddha et les disciples ont prié, entre guillemets, ils ont...
Ils n'ont pas intercédé auprès de quelqu'un, mais ils l'ont fait directement.
Quand le Vénérable envoie le Metta, disons, il ne va pas demander à quelqu'un d'autre, mais il va le faire directement.
Je peux seulement espérer que cela vous fera du bien.
Karma est une forme de cause et d'effet.
Karma est ce dont nous avons parlé hier, votre Sankara.
Le karma, c'est une force.
Oui.
Bien sûr.
Et parfois, vous faites des choses avec le bonheur du cœur et vous obtenez une réponse très mauvaise.
On fait un bienfait et après on reçoit en retour, disons, des mauvaises choses.
Alors il y a une organisation charitable qui envoie des vêtements en Afrique.
Quand les habits arrivent en Afrique, ils ont réuni l'industrie, comment ça s'appelle, locale.
Et l'industrie locale s'effondre.
Alors, ils ont dû repatrier, envoyer les habits.
Compassion sans sagesse, c'est un problème.
Même si vous êtes la personne la plus, disons, pleine de compassion, disons, qui aime tout le monde, il y aura toujours quelqu'un pour vous détester.
Ok ?
Ça va ?
Alors, pouvons-nous juste faire une petite bénédiction, et puis nous allons le faire aujourd'hui.
Juste...
Sous-titrage ST' 501 Sous-titrage ST' 501 Sous-titrage ST' 501
May you enjoy great good fortune, may all the powers that be, the force be behind you, the Dhamma, and may you receive all the blessings of the Buddha, Dhamma and Sangha.
Top of tea.
British obsession.
Oui, laissez-moi prendre l'occasion aussi de vous remercier, et de remercier le Vénérable ici pour l'organiser, et bien sûr notre merveilleux traducteur, le merveilleux, le merveilleux Jung.
Et merci au Vénérable d'Amica pour avoir organisé les deux jours de méditation.